the libs are mocking Trump and they're
mocking Trump over things that they know
nothing about like this guy on SNL Trump
did have a slight stumble this week
while talking about Banks and he
introduced an interesting new term
called debank we're also going to place
strong protections to stop Banks and
Regulators from trying to debank you
they want to debank you and we're going
to
debank I don't know what the hell debank
means but he might have to take D
ambulance to see the doctor
this guy doesn't know what debank means
because liberals have never had to deal
with
it and because he doesn't read the news
and because the news he does read
doesn't tell him what's actually going
on in politics and because he didn't
even Google it and doesn't even he
didn't even read the Wikipedia page
about de
banking this is this is not Trump
sometimes makes up words like koffe but
this is not a word he made up this is a
real phenomenon and it's when liberals
wield their institutional political
power not necessarily in the government
but in the the supposedly private sector
that makes up all the rest of our life
and they wield their soft power in those
areas to deprive people of their bank
accounts that's what they do and it's
happened a lot you especially see this
in the United
Kingdom Trump or rather Nigel farage
who's the British Trump Nigel farage
leader of brexit he had his his bank
taken away from him ostensibly for
political reasons Stuart Campbell
who's a Scottish independence activist
he had his bank taken away and the
reason appears to be because he
criticized wokeness and
specifically Anglican vicer Reverend
Richard
fathergill he got his bank taken away
why it appears to be over the too and
you could be next these Libs have never
heard of this because they don't have to
deal with it there's no risk that that
you know the conservatives who control
the banks are going to take away their
their checking accounts that's never
going to happen there's no such thing
there's zero risk and they don't read
any of the news and the fake news media
that that you know constitute the New
York Times And The Washington Post and
NBC and ABC and all of the the outlets
that they read they just don't report on
this stuff because it's
unflattering amazing now not one writer
at one of the biggest shows at one of
the big TV networks had ever even heard
of a major political tactic wielded by
the Liberals against the
conservatives 69% of Voters side with
Joe side with sorry Texas over Joe Biden
this according to a new poll from Ras M
only 27% of Voters oppose Texas taking
action to prevent illegal
immigration uh this breaks down even
across constituencies that are not often
on the side of conservatives uh black
voters overwhelmingly vote Democrat and
yet according to this poll 51% of black
voters side with Texas only 32% of black
voters disagree two-thirds of
Independence side with Texas only 29%
disagree this is a huge losing issue for
Democrat which is exactly why Biden and
the Democrats are pushing this
terrible terrible immigration Bill
through the
Senate right now you may have heard
about it it's it's percolating in the
background
the a bipartisan Committee of
civic-minded Republicans and Democrats
are getting together to pass a stinking
garbage heap of an immigration Bill
through the Senate and the only reason
it's coming up is because this issue is
has gotten so bad for Democrats among
groups that they need to win to maintain
their
power that they're trying to hang their
hat on anything I've said from the
beginning the bill is terrible the first
reason that this bill is terrible
is because the Democrats are currently
in violation of the law it's it's not as
though there's no law to deal with these
migrants oh we've never seen anything
like this we need to get together and
find a solution there are many many
immigration laws on the books that the
Democrats are intentionally not
enforcing and when the states are
enforcing them the Joe Biden and the
federal government come in and stop the
States from enforcing them so there can
be no negotiation with the Democrats
here the Democrats are proving
themselves every second of every day to
not being negotiating in good faith why
should I pass some new law about
immigration when I know for a fact today
Democrats are not enforcing the current
law on immigration I should have
absolutely no trust that the Democrats
will enforce anything they'll take the
goodies that we give them it'll be it'll
be like the Ragan amnesty all over again
they'll take the amnesty that we give
them and they will not give us any of
the enforcement in return as has
happened time and time
again fool me once shame on you fool me
twice fool me three times to quote
George W bush the point is you're not
going to fool me again that's that's
what we're looking at here it'd be one
thing if they had returned and were even
sort of pretending to enforce the law
they're not so there's no reason to
believe that but then what the bill
would do affirmatively is is awful too
absolutely awful this has being pushed
by the Oklahoma senator Jim Langford and
the Oklahoma GOP has actually just voted
to condemn and censor this supposedly
Republican senator because he's pushing
this bill that's great news I called for
that yesterday okay maybe they watch the
show I don't know I don't want to take
credit if but you know who knows hey in
any case glad it's happening anyone who
votes for this rancid garbage heap of a
bill deserves to be thrown out of the
Republican party I'm I'm pretty broad
minded as you know I try to be fair to
all the candidates and different
perspectives in the GOP I've been very
nice about the presidential race this is
just heinous this is this is political
suicide for the Republicans Not only
would voting for this be deeply unjust
it's political suicide you're just
trying to give the Democrats an
out the fact that we're even negotiating
this bill is giving Democrats an out
because if it fails as I hope it does
then the Democrats can say well
Republicans they wouldn't they wouldn't
come to a solution On the Border you got
a solution folks it's already on the
books Democrats are free to enforce the
law if they want they don't want to
because they want an invasion they just
want a py to blame it on and and Rhino
Republicans in the Senate seem more than
willing to be that py to to be the the
court gure in the Kingdom of liberalism
which is what what these pseudo
conservatives always do in the bill what
this bill would do according to CBS News
the agreement is expected to give the
executive branch a new legal authority
to effectively suspend asylum in
official ports of entry in between
official ports of Entry when migrant
Crossings surpass certain thresholds
okay hold on so the executive branch
will have a new legal authority to
suspend Asylum and the ex Branch already
has authority to arrest people who enter
our country illegally the executive
branch already has authority to
streamline Asylum claims and Deport
people who who manifestly don't qualify
the executive branch has this Authority
already they could just inforce the law
no they would give them new
ones and they could even suspend this
these Asylum claims once you hit certain
thresholds of Crossings okay what are
the
thresholds this is amaz this according
to CBS News some rightwing
Outlet the uh the suspension of these of
the Border would be mandated after
average daily migrant Crossings hit
5,000 over 7
Days 35,000 people cross in a week okay
all of a sudden now the president can
start to take a look maybe slow things
down a little bit 35,000 foreigners
Crossing into our country illegally or 8
8,500 in a single day 8500 people in a
day it's uh by my math 85,000 people in
10 days and then by by my math that's
850,000
people in a 100 days so you're talking
about in a 100 days you're upwards of a
million people but there's what 300 uh
you know 365 some odd days in a
year so now you're looking at millions
and millions of these okay now we can
spend it for a little bit but not for
too long not for too long there would
also be a limit on the number of days
each year the president could invoke
this Authority so you know he shuts it
down for a few days when you got 8,500
people in a single day Crossing but then
eventually he can't invoke it anymore
and they
cross are you kidding me this is the
Great Compromise oh thank you with
Republicans like this who needs
Democrats any Republican in the Senate
who votes for this
bill certainly should be
primaried should probably be thrown out
of the GOP it's it's so egregious on an
issue that is so fundamental even Beyond
migration it's just about the do we have
a rule of law or not and on an issue
that is such a political winner for the
current Republican position I can't
unless these people just want to lose
they want to get rid of our borders
flood our country and just lose anything
resembling conservative governance I
have no idea what they are thinking man
what a great clip that was now hold up
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel and we will see
you next time